hi
my name is greg alba and i'm with the
real rejects
hi oh my god uh i am so excited i know i
only got a little bit of time with you
guys
and you're the two i wanted to talk with
the most so much so that i'm actually
out of town at a wedding and they don't
know but i snuck out of the wedding and
rushed back to the hotel just to talk to
you guys
so and you got the t-shirt on and
everything i had it underneath the whole
time i'm like i'm ready to do this let's
go
oh that's the biggest pop i could ever
receive thank you my first question's
from margo uh you're
always perfect as harley but this time
around i would
really move by different reasons in
large part due to like what's going on
underneath the surface
you have your own story for a large part
of it there's this fantastic demented
scene with the luna character
and while the humor of her is still
present i really felt connected to the
darkness within her so
i was wondering can you clue us in as to
some of the homework you did as an actor
for what she's going through here that
may not be fully communicated solely
through dialogue
yeah it's something that actually we
really laid the foundations about when
we did the first film
and david air really wanted to explore
the really like dark ugly side of all
the characters in particular harley
and there is a lot of trauma there and
um you know a lot of it stemming from a
very toxic relationship with mr j
and in this film the suicide squad james
has written this beautiful sequence this
kind of monologue
where harley starts out saying you know
i'm on the lookout you know so i don't
get a bad boyfriend again essentially
but then you get a bit of an insight of
like what it really cost her
all those things that mr j have done to
her and maybe it's
you know slashing her tires or trying to
kill her
or just telling her that her taste in
music is [ __ ]
you know whatever it was it gets really
real and emotional for a second
and um again just a little glimpse of
the trauma that uh
stemmed from that very very
dysfunctional relationship she was in
i love that scene i was just like
cringing the whole time in all the right
ways i loved it so much
and um for david i've said this on many
youtube videos
you're like the king of appearing in
comic book properties
and i'm so happy you've crafted a
character but we only barely got to
scratch the surface of in terms of
backstory
but like everyone i've talked to you
were all shades of sympathetic you're
weird as hell but badass when you
shouted
i'm a superhero i just had this big grit
on my face
but i thought the past we hinted at
entailed so much weird but
cool sci-fi body horror trauma stuff and
we didn't get to see the kind of life
that this character had that led him to
being captured by waller
would you want to do a standalone movie
and if so what would you
really like to explore about his
backstory
thanks for saying that and i god i loved
getting doing body abner and getting to
bring him to life and james wrote such a
complex and beautiful character with him
and as someone who loves and appreciates
comic books i do think that
it can be such a great lens when you
tell these big stories with cinema
for going to some dark and interesting
places when people
least expect that to occur so
if we were to go further back into
abner's past one of the things that
is really funny funny whatever is the
right word but james didn't know this
about me
when i was a kid i was diagnosed with an
autoimmune disorder called vitiligo and
i have it to this day and i have spots
all over my body and it was something
that
riddled me with anxiety and paranoia and
like just completely being so
embarrassed of my body
literally until about 12 years ago when
i met my wife who just thought that my
spots were the coolest thing
but i would love to tell the story about
that journey like young abner up to
um you know because because his are just
these more
visceral manifestations of something
that i feel like i really get you know
and it has to star actually harley but
let abner be in it
i i'll just i'll be i'll be a supporting
character
i love that um thank you guys both so
much i love the hell out of this movie
and you were the two that i requested to
talk with so
i feel like i won the lottery just now
thank you both so much enjoy the rest of
the wedding
thank you so much please congratulate
them from us okay
they'll see you jake thank you guys
take care
you